the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright alright so we're going to
continue now and kind of get into the
examples part of the of the course and
again this is really the part that
people should really I I strongly
encourage people doing the examples how
many people got a chance to try the
examples in the very good and we got a
couple of questions for people and and
most of the time we got another email
from them right away that said Oats no
got it to work so we're very pleased
about that very you know the great thing
about working at Lincoln labs is people
are pretty good at figuring stuff out we
have some experience this than before
obviously are parallel men now left
technology we've released that out many
many people used it and for the most
part we're proud to say that whenever we
get a question from the outside world
and it's not working it's it's using a
person hasn't taken severely active
steps to ignore the documentation you
know and and and but if they follow it
at all they're generally pretty pretty
safe so I'm going to get into the
example code here so the example code
this is oh that's not the forum users
share that's incorrect it's tools lower
case examples I should correct these
slides
oh nice go great it is an x-ray oh yes
thank you great all right so this is
where the example code is but we're
going to go over here on your assignment
should you choose to undertake it is to
pick a picture hopefully someone that's
interesting to you doesn't have to be
straight lines it could be anything
where you could create draw edges or
something you take some photo and put it
through one of those Photoshop effects
and turn it into a line drawing or
something then start labeling vertices
um you do want to limit the number of
lines though I would recommend 20 would
be the most number of lines you do
because this can get fairly involved you
might start with something fairly small
so select a picture label the edges and
vertices create an incidence matrix okay
and then just compute the adjacency
matrix from the incidence matrix using
this this formula you can certainly use
D for EM if you want to do that but it's
fine to do it by hand it's fine to do it
by hand just in which case you would
want to do a very small one just you
know doing it once by hand is is useful
you know twice marginally and then the
third time I'm not useful but just like
in high school right they make you do
matrix multiply by hand like actually a
lot you know hopefully so so that's the
example in the assignment um if you do
this on a piece of paper and scan it and
email it to me before the next lecture I
will get you give you some feedback on
it before the following a lecture so you
know you sanded give it to me after that
you bad all right no no I just won't
give you feedback you know so
there's no credit but you know this
gives you some incentive to get it done
if you want feedback from me about you
know what you did make sense or if you
encounter like I picked this picture and
now I don't understand you know what I
did my best but I have questions about
how i did this you know does it make
sense I'll be happy to good so just scan
it email it to me or if it is electronic
format you know you can do that as well
so the lecture portion and now go back
here and let's see here we go two
examples all right so we're in the intro
edge art directory start my aunt lab
shell right place takes about 15 seconds
for to do this
this particular thing always CDs me to
the location of the directory you need
to do that in order to see the examples
I think most matlab users but just some
that some that are not hide that here is
the actual adjacency matrix of that
painting so there it is same thing we
just saw so this is the data set that
we're going to work with here alright so
I'm going to do a one again the numbered
one you know the courses the all
examples are numbered in order kind of
that you're supposed to proceed through
them and if you see kind of a file in a
directory that's like capital couple
capital letters which are the first two
letters of the directory for the
abbreviation of the directory and a test
that is the examples the other files are
just supporting files you don't are
expected to run those try running them
but they'll probably cause you problems
if you run them by themselves all right
here we go so we just ran that example
let's see what we got let me a little
bit smaller bigger
alright I think that worked alright so
first thing we did here is we great read
in our data so we have this read CSV or
useful function not necessary the
fastest and some of the later examples
we have a servo super fast reader which
does almost no formatting for you so
just reads in the triples as raw triples
because a lot of times if you're reading
a very large CSV file you may not want
to construct the full associative array
out of the way we would just sort of do
it by default and you can just read in
the triples very quickly then do some
manipulation zor a lot of times the
first thing you'll do is recreate an
associative array and then get the
triples out of it because you want to
work on the triples directly and so so
we do have ways for doing that so this
is the we now created the incidence
matrix into an associative array and go
down here let me just show you that if I
go disc so that shows you the incidence
matrix these are its internal structures
here these are the row keys so those are
the recall the labels of the edges they
have been converted to LexA graphically
or sorted order we have the column keys
but there's so many that that MATLAB
chooses not to print out the full list
here but it's again a LexA graphically
sorted list of the unique on labels
these are the different values that we
have so these says you remember we had
an order column which is one two three
blue green orange pink silver etc and
here you know and then the overall
adjacency matrix which connects the row
keys to their value keys is 19 by 21 19
19 rose
21 columns this actually shows a
mixed-use right some of these are
essentially exploded right the fact that
we have each each edge but some of the
values are actually storing real stuff
here blue green orange etc so you don't
have to go all the way with one you can
mix them to around you can create dense
matrices that look more like traditional
tables and there's some times that you
want to do that and other times you can
serve completely explode it out and do
things like that as well so we go back
we just want to work with the vertices
okay so we're going to ignore this color
and order column so we're going to
create our first projection is to just
work with the vertices so we have this
little shorthand here called starts with
if you give it a character and it will
create a little query little that will
get just things that start with that and
very useful thing is very efficient to
that actually formally creates the two
boundary it figures out what the maximum
range is for that and it just needs to
look up you know the beginning and the
end it consume LexA graphical order and
it can just grab the middle so much we
have a regular expression approach to
which works fine on small associative
arrays but this is much more efficient
because it's just basically two lookups
and go it also works if this e was
actually a binding to a table in a
database you can use the same syntax
while the regular expression syntax
doesn't really work yes so that's the
delimiter of the string so it's a string
list with one entry in it so this is a
string list all our strings are lists
here well because this also allows me
could have been anything that was that
was unique to that okay and it didn't
have to be the same delimiter that was
the one inside could have been a new
line could have been a tab could
whatever i just picked comma because it
was convenient but could have been a
space on because you can have multiple
arguments to this
starts with you want to say i want
starts with this and starts with this
and search with this you just give it a
whole list and we'll go and do that all
for you and so that's why we do it that
way wherever possible we try and accept
a list of strings and then do kind of
the right thing so basically this saying
get get me all columns that start with
these so that will be all the vertices
and this is the colon which says you
know and I want the full row of that
these had these values of which were the
the order group that they were in and
and so we don't care about those we want
to convert them back to regular numeric
numbers and so we have this shorthand
here called double logi which basically
just takes the logical and then does the
double I think mathematically formally
you would use to call this the Infinity
norm on strings if that even makes sense
but it basically just says if there's a
value there converted to a you know a
double precision one if there's not a
value there it's just a sparse zero not
one and we do this all the time because
a lot of times we want to do math on
these things it's like regular math we
want to compute the vertex adjacency
graph so we do that with our square in
function here our inner square product
so that basically takes our matrix and
use the edge is the common key to join
them together and we use our display
full function to actually show what we
got and so now you see the vertex vertex
adjacency matrix here and then the
number is the number of times those
vertices are on the same edge so it's
obviously symmetric and you see here so
you know these vertices here which are
part of this common hyper edge you know
we have this sort of 696 structure here
various other types of symmetric
structures going on here showing you the
counts how many times those vertices
appeared on the same edge these are
obviously clicks because they are all
vertices that are on the same hyper edge
line so if you have a same hyper edge
line whenever you do the squaring
operation you create you see it as this
click in
in this in this operation here all right
we can also do the square out function
okay which computes the edge jason c
major so now we want to ask which edges
share common vertices and so that's this
structure here it shows you the these
are the various edges and again it's
symmetric and you can see all kinds of
structures in here about which vertices
share which edges should have share
common common vertices so and that is
pretty much it for this example very
simple example hopefully gets you to the
point where you can begin to try out the
homework assignment and if there's any
questions the people have you know you
know let's try this here one thing
that's fun to do spy e works
oats
come on guy I think between PowerPoint
quicktime and everything else is just
about up there it is wow that's a long
time so this shows that adjacency matrix
so spy works I think we shouldn't we
showed that in the first example but the
spy function the standard matlab sparse
plotting function very useful way to
just sort of look at the stuff all those
previous charts i showed you on the
examples we've done this thing and a
little feature that sometimes causes
matlab to crash because it doesn't
really like doing things too
aggressively but if you click on it it
shows you the row and the column and the
value associated with that and also
prints it out here likewise here so you
see row column eight gives you the order
this tells you you know the row was g2
its column is color its value this green
so actually i lied to you that was just
the first example senior moment there we
have two more to go a lot more fun than
see you're all you're all excited to
class ended early so alright here's the
other examples so again what we do is
reading in the data set we're displaying
the full thing so you can see there's
the full beast i just showed you with
the spy plot now i'm going to do some
analytics on this so one thing i want to
do is just get to orange edges so i can
say get me the column color and because
orange is held in the value i can
actually compare it with the string so i
say return me the matrix the associative
array of the row color and everything
equal to orange that returns me another
associative array the result of this
whole logical expression is another
associative array i can then get the
rose those associative arrays that
association I've found all edges that
are orange and I can then pass that get
those rows and pass that back
to the original one to get just the
orange edges so this just shows you sort
of this composable ability that's very
powerful same same ability to now that
as one does similar statements and
malleable the time and so it's very
composable to be a very complex query to
do in other approaches and you can do it
very quickly here yes question ah no it
doesn't it doesn't what we could do is
overloaded so if you passed in an
associative array with just a single
argument and have it behave like when
you pass in the matlab logical and do
that kind of intersection we could think
about that but matlab actually relies on
then converting the matrix to a vector
and then using the singular basically it
takes that logical converts it to a
single airiness which kind of gets us
into an area where it's very fuzzy and
gray so we've definitely thought about
that and it's it's it's it's there are
places where we line up with matlab very
nicely because of the mathematics of
associative arrays and linear algebra
really line up very nicely and there's
there's there's and there's places where
they intersect there's things you can do
in with associative arrays that you
can't do with linear algebra for example
we can mult matrix multiply any two
associative raised there's no
conformance requirement that they don't
have the same normally when you multiply
two matrices the number of the
dimensions have to the interdimensions
have to match basically the columns of
the left argument and the rows of the
right argument must be the same length
and associate arrays that requirement
doesn't exist you can multiply or add
any two associative arrays we'll get
into that much more in the next class
but that's a very powerful feature that
people like but there's other places
where it doesn't really make sense so
things like what is the upper triangular
section of an associative array gets to
be a little bit huh what's that mean
so excellent question though excellent
question there so we can display this so
this just shows we found all the edges
that had color orange but we don't have
to just you know that's a way of using
the values to select we could of course
use starts with in the Rose just say
starts with 0 ng i just happen to label
all my rose that orange rose began with
0 and green rose begin with G so we can
do starts with 0 g so that's example of
those two range queries being done at
the same time and so that gives us EOG
and again we can see now we get the
orange and green rose so that just shows
you that and then we'll wrap up here
with the last example which is VA 3 all
right now we get to do some really fun
stuff again we're reading in reading in
our data set converting just getting the
vertices ok and then converting it to
numeric zeros and ones I'm going to now
just get the orange edges and I'm going
to get the green edges all right and now
I'm going to essentially do the cross
correlation of the orange and green
engine so I'm going to transpose one of
them and matrix multiply with the other
ones we don't do square in here because
they're different matrices in fact I
would say that people often do the
cross-correlation more often than just
square the matrix with itself you have
one set with another set and you want to
cross correlate them a very common
operation and so that's just transpose
you know evg here and that gets that and
as you can see the results of that inner
product was empty alright but the result
of the outer product is full so that's
just and you guys can think about why
that is and so this just shows you the
the common how many edges
these appeared with together this shows
you that there was no what you guys can
figure that out I'll let you go home now
another thing that we often want to do
is basically this showed us which edges
had common vertice you know shared
vertices together okay but it didn't
tell us we lost we lost the actual
vertices we just know that there's three
a lot of times we want them this is
sometimes called the pedigree you do a
correlation and then you would like but
what you say these two things are
correlated should I want to get the the
connector back to the original records
so I can go back to my email and really
find that out and present that as the
evidence that these things are connected
together we don't want to lose that so
we have invented special new matrix
multiplies in the land of associative
arrays one of them we call a cat key
mall okay which the view the matrix
multiplied as sort of there's a key a
common key this row column key that's
being sort of joined together well we
can preserve that and store that in the
value instead of say the couch or
something like that so we do cat chemo
EV 0 transpose EVG and then when we
display that we not only see which edges
were connected but we also have
preserved the list of the vertices is
essentially a concatenated list of those
keys very useful thing one has to be so
very powerful technique one definitely
has to be careful about using this
technique if it generates going to
generate extremely extremely long lists
here that can really cause this to
behave very slowly in particular one has
to be careful of if you do a cat chemo
on a matrix with itself why do you think
you would have to be careful with that
anyone remember that dense diagonal that
happened whenever we squared matrices so
that means this thing
you will have an enormous number of
entries along the diagonal so you have
to be very careful when you use this
kind of function to correlate something
with itself it's better to correlate two
distinct sets because they tend to not
have that a dense diagonal which can be
a little bit of a problem there's ways
to get around that I mean there's hacks
and tricks and stuff like that but at a
certain level really dense diagonals I
mean you essentially be listing every
single vertex in your data set you could
be listing every single vertex in your
dataset almost every single time you
know multiple times along the diagonal
that would be get very very bulky so
just a little word of caution there and
so now I've dated you once but this
really is the end so are there any
questions on the examples before we put
it off here is there a question back
here somewhere no all right great thank
you very much appreciate it and we'll
see you next week and again think of a
picture draw some lines make an
incidence matrix have fun with it
compute the degree of your significant
other bad idea